and I understand that this podcast
tonight was a little weird
we did some music I talked about little
people we talked about other things it
was a little choppy in and out but let
me say something it is what it is
and I'm not gonna worry about isn't
enough time or are they having
entertaining you know I'm tired and I'm
frazzled but I'm still doing the best I
can to put out the best thing okay
and you know you know I could put nut
juice on the wall you can smear nut
juice on a wall all day long babe you're
allowed you know why Cinelli okay so
what see right now water when I was in
at it I was in Chicago my little
Brazilian girl the girl girl she's I
would say jade is probably like wife
number two she's your work wife no she's
[ __ ] she looks sick no I'm just
saying when you're on the road she's
like her yeah I love Jade so Jade had
her other friend her friend who was a a
baker in a nice restaurant and she and
we're they were hanging out and they go
well how many times you go to proof to
me I never heard of it
they go they have the best sandwiches in
the world and and it's in Atwater
Village it's my favorite sandwich of all
time damn she really simple like what
about you Pam there's only two different
kinds really salami and ham but they're
pre-made they're in like a basket and
you just go I'll have and they did just
give it to you Wow I think it's the
ratios that are really perfect Wow hey
proof if you're listening or open the
sponsors it's a little bakery that's run
by Asians oh really nice and cute but
anyway give me another podcast I mean
give me another arm
[Music]